so cool to learn that why is it say it here
why do they tell us who's in a movie because
it might sell it I know that would have been
so cool do your job he's in this movie we
just learned about Pedro B we didn't know
this moment what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we have come back to
finish off the franchise equalizer two get
ready for koi genre and Greg Alba to ruin
this movie because we're gonna talk over it
because otherwise we're watching in silence
but you're gonna comment anyway some people
are like oh this is like movie commentary
as well as reaction now we're gonna do triple
the commentary for the 2.5 percent that hit
the dislike button we might miss more dialogue
making jokes that you hate just working fun
back at the few yeah my Nord because most
of you loved it but the ones that didn't we
read those comments that was my first time
re-watching McCoy that was his first time
reacting and watching ever and this one we're
going both in rand's bacon anyway guys leave
a like because we're gonna be doing this as
always you can catch our full-length ratchet
and watch along We sync up with your own copy
of The Equalizer too we are watching this
off Hulu cover several things exclusively
over the reaction highlights of watchalongs
included you excited uh he's got hair this
time so I'm reluctant but still in I know
I love I trust it I'm gonna prefer the bald
look yeah but that was just a still that's
true a lot of people love this one it has
less of an impact negatively than people said
about Kung Fu 3 and we both landed well in
kung fu 3. I don't know anything about it
I've not seen it have not seen her trailer
either
thank you
book 100 again great like between the world
and me is gonna set up so much I can feel
it hot water please
excuse me
playing the fool I don't trust his guess my
brother you say you can find whatever you
wish in Turkey how about a man who kidnapped
his own daughter and took her away from her
American mother yes you can find that in Turkey
maybe next year I would give him a chance
to stop to think about the worst thing that
could ever happen to him oh he's gonna go
for the strike
what's your watch yes
yes
hell yeah they're two kinds of pain in this
world
pain that hurts pain that alters bacon Sun
City Dixon
thank you
yeah I love him always giving someone a chance
like that's such a good narrative through
line my State Department doesn't know a thing
about it Grace just that 45 minutes ago someone
delivered your daughter to the desk downstairs
I'd say things got equalized this divorce
is equal
foreign
posters everywhere with that hat
he's a Lyft driver that's amazing uh how about
that though it's not easy getting in and out
copy center little this is Denzel's first
sequel huh other than Glory too I mean obviously
yeah okay thank you for this interview and
opportunity thank you for this opportunity
this is like a reverse on those horror movies
that every screenwriter pitches a Lyft driver
who's like a serial killer you know this guy
just helps people he just goes around wanting
to help we hit it correct first door yes sir
I'll be there to pick you up when you get
back I hope that is the end of the movie I
would love that same guy that would be a very
short time he served in Iraq just a week bro
unless this movie's fans like a long period
of time and a nine-day tour left you something
upstairs did you you're coming to the bathroom
yes I'm coming plates and napkins and forks
I like how he's more joyous he's got a whole
new life serves a purpose he feels vengeful
so I said
although this guy just looks oh my God oh
my God he's just like confused this whole
time he's not even like scared no threat just
gives Celtics just oh I mean business I got
your name on a piece of paper in my pocket
American stop talking your son's gonna be
home any second yeah open your mouth no no
open your mouth oh damn that is Sinister [Music]
this movie knows how to paint villain these
both these movies man that was what a minute
and he's like the worst yeah ordered a book
last week oh oh uh yeah he's a Lyft driver
but doesn't doesn't have Amazon 2018. come
on
oh she knows Secret oh he's just checking
in on her came in yesterday thank you what
number last one 100. sign is down oh it changes
circumstances not going anywhere now holes
I feel like if I was a mom I'd still kind
of want to know in case like what if my daughter
gets taken away from me like some closure
yeah I do like the added pep and Denzel of
like him feeling Vindicated what he's doing
now that I know Patriots and this I just keep
waiting for him to show up good guy or bad
guy what do you think I think he's totally
a bad guy yeah
go get in her apartment
oh man if you heard a woman he is going to
come after you on the Lyft driver that you
called take home your girlfriend not a girlfriend
man just an intern the uh credit card was
invalid let you hang with us because your
daddy's a client you [__] up the first
thing
I heard about these I've never seen one before
yeah well now you have look pay yourself whatever
and uh give yourself a nice tip
I'm a bad guy took it to Mass General to pumping
a stomach as we speak what's her name you
don't know do you oh I'm gonna need your cameras
cell phones anything you might have used to
record what you did to her record damn foreign
Score says he's The Equalizer he knocked on
the wrong door tonight pops oh my god with
the metal card
s oh [Music] what Merc just to a one big deal
towards call 9-1-1 you tell them the truth
about what happened in there tonight her name
is Amy give me your left hand give me your
left hand I like this yeah just the darkness
in him I expect the five-star rating you understand
not for me though for who Amy that's right
Amy
full-blown Darkness vigilante I love it I
know it's awesome and like making them so
deserving of his [__] scorn in like seconds
this is how he's earned all his five-star
ratings breaking hands leave one man alive
write me and tip me I just love how he just
resorts to kill him he's always got an outlet
like a rat to kill him cause he's over he's
like he's got us the time stamps as in the
tip
I can smell you hey oh he's got a new book
out maybe I should read in it yeah politics
of Nepal prior to the 1816 sigali treaty is
your bag definitely friendship has its limits
get expression I like that clever I realized
that I didn't have any clothes left that Vivian
had ever seen I don't know what happened to
those purple shirts that you used to buy and
and I put one on that she like wow this is
interesting mm-hmm go home huh make a piece
of it is what Vivian would have wanted but
we need equalizer three yeah we can't find
peace so screw Vivian's wishes sorry sorry
Vivian but you're dead you can't leave Boston
yeah like the first one was slowly revealing
who he was and now that we know who he is
we just get a zero in and it's like diving
deeper into details and personal and yeah
that's pretty cool and the immediacy of things
because the sequel we already know so the
villains are immediately like the worst and
it's very cool way to do a sequel oh what
on his Turf hey Mr McCall maybe you could
find out who did this the Fatima's Garden
kids well a bunch of kids are about to get
murdered in 30 seconds no Second Chances [Laughter]
hey it's the kid from American Saga Wu-Tang
he plays Rizza oh that's cool he's so good
dude this kid's so talented you should let
somebody else do this then like who you know
they got a they got painting companies around
here I know they charge six seven hundred
dollars to do the job I know that's said I'll
do this for 350. I'm an artist man I go to
Bridgeview us why aren't you in school I don't
be doing all them everyday classes
and it takes talent to make money but it takes
brains to keep it miles I wish Denzel was
my dad he's just a good dad from that one
second tell he's good because most of the
time a scene like that I would go sounds like
that's the actor's auditions yeah and instead
you're like he's keeping up with Denzel and
he's interesting and charismatic yeah he's
very believable yeah I've been thinking about
shawarfield and uh calibrating uh 250 I take
care of all of this for you
you can only work on it after school curse
what time you get out three for two okay after
school 3 15 deal cash all right okay cash
there he is clean cut Pedro yeah caliber did
work for us and when something occurs to one
of ours oh he's corrupt I think he might be
a good guy I don't know why is he second credited
maybe because it's Pedro
today I broke a personal best successive days
alive
it's great that's portrait of my sister Magna
my sister marked then I was sent to different
camps and I see somebody auctioning my painting
I got here the proof no record no bill of
sales he just keeps going back to court to
hear the same thing get in there get in there
do me a favor let's see what you can find
out yeah oh another dinner then I'm worried
she's gonna die I'm very worried she's more
likable more screen time yeah
sell records you'll have them later today
I'm gonna go bad guys still I'm gonna say
good guy but he gets in the way of Denzel
doing his job because he's by the book I don't
know she must have made the judge pay any
attention to me oh this poor guy my uncle
commissioned the portrait my little brother
she'd say my Sammy I could never protect her
to lose her twice this old guy is great he's
so good he's great yeah stayed on Calvert's
hard drive just came in no we'll talk about
it on the plane I want to get out of here
as soon as we can run some serious Buzz down
yeah hold on let's see I don't trust this
elevator ride about to get winter soldiered
I see you downstairs at six you got it and
how about some of that delicious Belgian chocolate
you're always talking about oh you're not
getting on the plane yes I'm going back out
oh no it's gonna happen isn't it we're gonna
we're gonna lose Pedro already no her oh yeah
she's gone this is it those two people we
met
no no this time she got too close equalizing
is personal oh great yeah
let her have a shot
[Music]
that's
lucious she's going for it man a castle this
entire building okay how much it's becoming
fences it's the Hat Man
soon he's going to start really criticizing
this gun angry or angry hey Brian yeah listen
I'm I'm reading your book right now and I
can't believe you
somebody's going to Belgium yo Mr McCoy you
good are yo Mr McCall
oh he even left this book The pacing of this
one's interesting is there's a lot more atmosphere
yeah they use the their environments a lot
more and just let that kind of be the the
mood and there's more subplots like there's
a lot like the old man him the kid like there's
a lot more going on it's sort of existentialism
quality like the questioning of purpose of
life and the the first book is between me
and the world which is like
I mean he can't attend this right he's supposed
to be dead oh yeah might be a tell Pedro totally
stuck them on her you think he's a bad guy
thousand percent you might be rapid help you're
not yeah but in these hotels these robberies
but she never wore any jewelry except for
this
they're working with Interpol promised to
find whoever it was it's a sorrowful experience
man I thought that was really interesting
the way he receives this is a very interesting
action franchise it really is because there's
so much dramatic heft in these films and most
people just talk about like the action scenes
but this is a real character
yeah there's like a other than you know obvious
death to grieve there is a grievance tone
throughout this whole movie yeah like from
beginning to end very sorrowful yep it's like
all even the subplots deal a lot with loss
and relax yeah yeah even the person with the
painting you know yeah he can't do you can't
accept it
people don't like when we make commentary
2.5 excuse us foreign
foreign
so many bad people we've met a lot of like
there's a lot more disparate villainy in this
or maybe it's not so I'm sure it'll it'll
congeal
is anyone else like super fascinated by this
franchise because he's committed so much violence
but then it's so interesting to see this moment
work because of someone he loves he can't
he can't and the violence is jarring now like
they shot it so I'm more repulsed by it yeah
that was really it was disturbing it was a
disturbing scene
you got fat Dave
he looks deep big he does because we're so
used to him grizzled yeah
you're dead oh wow I was in the same Lobby
when that bomb went off Susan she knew how
was your partner for seven years back I never
kept anything from you ah okay you still at
the beach not a long time well they got me
that cabin take the wife and kids up a couple
times a year if you have any of it it is so
cool seeing them together it is yeah yeah
I think he's a bad guy now but it's great
to see it yeah definitely a bad guy she never
pushed a button today oh it's losing on the
elevator she never pushed the floor number
I checked all the video Backpackers got on
first oh he looks nervous a couple of tweakers
the sheets as long as my arm gas explosion
at least that's what they're calling what
do you call it cover-up below a third rib
Close Quarter technique exactly that was taught
right whatever it is whatever you need same
mud same blood oh they're setting us up to
feel hurt right here pastel
not ready for it but I will be okay if we
end it is please baby's in three we don't
know
[Music] how he's got the the exact right apartment
to see them observe everything I mean he would
pick that he's moved somewhere he can still
be inconspicuous
that's why he likes courtyards
it's a neat movie man they're like away with
the mystery of his character now we're just
looking at the soul of him it's really cool
yeah it's there's no Discovery so it's a different
thing it's his I just expected like another
action like oh it's a seagull that should
be like cool action yeah
Vin Diesel can do this superpower too and
Fast and Furious very similar franchise Fook
was so good at dread and like making violence
so palpably uncomfortable next right side
he was right-handed why his wife his wife
while he left-handed somebody else was in
that room smart powder residue came from a
latex glove 20 000 Euros were found in the
Backpackers flat Susan was about to figure
out who was in that room that's why she was
killed Dave the two were connected he's doing
all the hard figuring out edger is going to
betray us and I'm not gonna like it I mean
he was his partner for seven years you think
he would have the skill set to match figure
in his house right yeah setting it up
don't kill miles just because he's late to
paint
yo man Elders closed oh
damn maybe he does these things because oh
choreography is so good he's so cool although
you could tell it's really Denzel doing it
too yeah
oh do we'll dig because it's the sequel two
guns equalized but two guns oh also two guns
a boom comic book yes no you got to spin the
bin yeah kill your brother yeah you gotta
go take care of that tonight run down boss
you can't be a killer I'm gonna kill all these
guys so you don't kill I'm the killer don't
come back without it empty [__] let's
go miles
let's go miles
you know him yeah he knows taking control
of the situation is it what you want I thought
you won the Droid now what you said that [__]
gonna pay the [__] bills you need to be
a killer a little yummy huh you need them
[__]
you know what they all did they liars and
so am I you know what happens when you deal
with a liar yeah he's really teaching a lesson
here you got talent you got a chance and I
want to hear about your environment what your
mama didn't give you and the white man won't
give you no shot you got a chance use it while
you're still alive you don't know what death
is
that was a great scene he's beat pushed to
the brink man kid is so good the mentorship
life guide and stuff and the first one and
some of the speeches like they all had heart
he's hit so much more real comfortable it
really is this ring so much more true in all
these scenes exchange for the extra p
would you like something to drink yeah come
on it I bet Denzel personally picked him I
almost guarantee it yeah what's she making
your mom's makes the same thing yeah
and this is not your house you understand
yeah teacher matters
yo this is why I need a paint job see it does
I could do it for you could you how much I
could get a plate of that food
115 right yeah can you read chilihisi Coast
between the world and me all right you read
that we got a deal
oh man I don't know if I'd still read it though
that lack of judgment and can you read man
like so many great what up what a beautiful
movie here boy yeah this is somebody's birthday
my daughter
uh-oh uh oh he knows how did he specifically
get him to pick him up yeah the Uber riding
thing I guess you don't fly that often you've
been driving in the opposite direction of
Logan for the last three minutes
ah [Music]
he's gonna take him out with one elbow and
a car it's all it takes someone eats
whoa these are great shots [Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
oh dude that was great that was a really well
done sequence that was so cool now pick up
your next Ride three minutes away five stops
[Music]
man and you know who stuck that guy on him
that first guy and Pedro past cage Roman because
he was getting onto him I know I don't want
to believe it
I love the build up of this storm yeah we're
gonna get some kind of cool Crescendo aren't
we more rain Denzel the dentist gonna be the
gardener grapes what if he's a good guy no
this is where the movie tries to convince
you it might have I Believe In You Pedro seriously
baby
Pedro being a daddy again I think I think
Louie's trying to convince us the archetype
that he's going to betray him I I'm team Pedro
I'm back I'm back team good guy honey the
front doorbell is broken your old army buddy
was at the back door for almost five minutes
actually I was his team leader seven years
I got the days mixed up this is Robert McCall
this is my wife Carol hi he was waiting for
something else specifically [Music] um
let's go you all right yeah he thought he
was dead all right it's working because I
just love Peter Pascal I took this off the
guy who tried to kill me yesterday whoever
we're looking for made call for that phone
what's he on the lookout for
[Music]
I wanted to believe
government shut us down I went private right
after now there's a price next to them we
killed the enemy who said they were the enemy
we just followed orders it's fair it's fair
no one knew the Brussels contract was a deep
agency asset Susan was going to figure out
who was in that dining room until you crawled
out of your grave
oh he revealed himself to her
to all of us all right Resnick Kovac all of
us oh wow gentlemen that's pretty good for
a dead guy we all want you to know none of
this is uh personal
ity oh he found his equals the mistake you
made was you killed my friend so I'm gonna
kill each and every one of you and the only
disappointment in it for me is that I only
get to do it once his family's in the background
I love that Dave said you could give me a
lift to the uh station help and Company let's
go see help end company
okay
oh damn come on oh you thought smiling I love
it oh it's so good I love it perfect I thought
equalizer 3 is coming later because this might
not have done well but I'm beginning to think
that's why because I put a lot of thought
into the movie yeah like I had to reshape
it to be something special so thought like
it's the way it's executed is like really
thought out like this is a shorter run time
but it feels so much more patient there's
so much more Nuance to this franchise than
most
he knows how they move he knows what they
would do he was the leader
oh no I'm so worried your National crib actually
oh you got any food around here I'm starving
oh no
I was just some dude out here delivering pizza
you really bought pizzas this is making me
hungry like the last but different well we
actually had pizza boxes yeah just in case
for the weight it's got to look good I'm like
two extra large pepperoni pizzas for this
marriage no no I'm hungry
It's gotta hide the silence for two bro miles
listen to me real careful go to the bedroom
go to my bedroom you'll see a bookshelf
what you'll see a button behind it I want
you to push the button miles
that's cool I want to install one of those
I really want a safe house bookcase yeah that's
really cool be quiet
don't worry
be quiet much quieter miles
yo man I don't do well in small spaces H looking
right at me don't worry about it
this is scary it's so nice damn you really
don't want him to die
oh come on he might have prepared for every
detail [__]
smart interrupt him interrupt him you thought
you could catch me here huh huh
since you're in my house what are my plans
smart yeah but he waited till the last minute
yeah you know where I'll be [Music]
um yeah
huh
I don't know where he's headed I was interesting
rack Focus situation he's going to the hardware
store Showdown where we must fight it's a
Home Depot story kid
I'd wait hours I don't know why people in
movies I'd be like I'm gonna weigh like several
hours I'm gonna sleep here and then yeah and
wait till the morning
literally no reason to leave you should oh
back up dude should have stayed for a lot
longer that was the one decision in this movie
hey I mean I it's it's because the kid's naive
and scared they set that out but still yeah
just got off a double shift just gonna check
and see if I left my gas on all right make
it quick let the great BMW grow th oh I want
to buy a BMW I wonder where that came from
wow look at that wow beautiful done the storm's
it's bigger than I expected I didn't know
they go coastal with this storm Zeus is going
to throw lightning bolts from the sky it's
gonna become a little crafty in Philippines
so tense that's a really suspenseful scene
what a beautiful last setting an abandoned
town and like the throes of Madness in the
mouth of Madness ah Lovecraft who often had
his work in Massachusetts that was his wife's
Bakery [Applause]
I think Pedro played this role great yeah
like it sometimes when you find out someone's
a villain there's like a total switch but
it feels like the same guy and I bought the
duplicitousness until they had to make me
believe like it was great
again so much more use of environment yeah
and another great setting for the finale instead
of being inside they're outside this time
still rain not yet but it'll come oh yeah
what an expensive set I know I feel like the
whole movie was like this is a lot more simplified
the way they did a lot of this but then this
this whole sequence look this is really Thriller
money right yeah the weather environment building
insane
I got moved at 12 o'clock locking down south
side I love how Denzel has hasn't even threaded
to release the information he's like I'm just
gonna kill you yep that's it that is a good
way to escalate the stakes in the beginning
show he's willing to give her more nah no
no no more
murder
there's a lot of cool locked off shots in
this one Anton Fuqua discovered GoPro great
sound design too with this setting
the eyeball lock off that's intense
oh hell yeah put his hand in there or his
face
fell for the old mirror trick push towards
the ocean [Music]
cool this movie has surprised me so much it's
such a different tone Oh wow
oh [__] whoa whoa whoa so you got all
the nerves oh whoa whoa Wicked povs
wow great shot
foreign
I got a blood trail looks like he's headed
across the main to the bakery
you're gonna die up there dude
I love this aesthetic so much
it's like a video game fight it really is
[Music]
come back oh my god oh
God just me and you dating nobody's left not
exactly
I mean yeah I guess they're safer up there
I mean the kid's not with them always have
a contingency plan oh that's right I totally
forgot about him miles there yeah so pulled
into the Bowman I wasn't even thinking ahead
show yourself and I won't kill the kid
oh great the wood makes it interesting
tail light
oh did they actually get clipped time's up
man
oh it's smart damn he just had to like glance
at the hit him like [__] it he just
the
wind does make it interesting
Susan and you're not gonna save this dude
yourself oh [__] what the hell you got
up there foreign
[Music]
oh
man the amount of nerves severing huh the
pain of that death yeah but his lips yeah
he just cut him apart yeah oh you did get
slightly clipped yeah you get clipped on that
taillight trying to think
oh is this his home oh yeah he eventually
did go back home yeah it went in and out it's
not bad my mom's just gonna be pissed yo not
at me man that's true
you talked everything all right
we didn't see her what she looked like huh
in the first movie I don't think so
In Search of Lost Time the book's right there
uh her glasses oh it was her last book yeah
it was back to the book it was her copy come
on sit down
they were meant to hand off the franchise
to miles that's what three is yeah a young
passing of the Baton what are you drawing
working on a superhero character what's Fountain
he equalizes those things before you do so
yes uh secret rooms magic locks back I appreciate
that Oh I thought she was gonna be like what
are you gonna call him The Equalizer too it's
Denzel Washington wow Robert painted all that
oh what about the old man yeah I think that's
got to be the ending or picking up the guy
at the airport but what's the old man what's
the paint
I leave you the best of myself with the signature
right there yeah I wonder if the old man painted
that
when I went on if you could just give me a
moment okay oh my God he got it for him
oh wow oh that's even crazier man Sammy
oh oh
my God
what is this sequel this is a while
this is this movie really surprised me man
it's so different than any other little genre
this is this is like a drama this is a drama
man
where is its paint on its sleeves man [Music]
uh the two chairs I thought it was beautifully
let him sit there like that moment for them
they apples
wow not the movie I expected not at all there's
not even like there's not even like callbacks
to the first one they don't do any of that
like sequel [__] other than you you know
characters that continue over if like Bill
Pullman and Melissa but there there's no like
winks and nods we don't know how you know
what's her name's doing like it just it just
moves security guard guy from the first movie
yeah oh yeah are you clear Grace from rats
you were talking about yeah they don't they
don't even bother with any no they just like
yeah and they it really gets you like invested
in this this story that was that was so surprised
I was I I was so surprised by just how different
it was the entire time and in a great way
like the first was more fun yeah um but this
like sucked me in into the drama of it all
the first one's like 70 John Wiki in action
20 drama ten percent like Thriller this one
was like 60 drama 20 Thriller 10 action and
10 I don't even know what like there's a there's
a new thing here like it's very tense and
palpable pain yeah there's there's like action
sequences if anything in the movie segues
into being more of what it wants to be like
it starts off like the beginning of this movie
is what I thought the whole movie was gonna
feel like yeah yeah yeah the opening is like
more like the first movie yeah the opening
is eyes like look at him in a disguise that
he's he's equalizing yeah jumping at this
little girl like cool and to remind you and
it catches you up and it puts you in the like
this is what the movie and then it just then
it transitions it's slowly but the transition's
quick once the killing happens yeah then it
changes genres as soon as the same type of
death because we're both like oh they're good
at the villain it felt like they were just
setting up the new villain in the same way
yeah and then it changed immediately and it
never came back I thought we were okay that
guy's our villain of the movie Let's uh we
don't see him for another hour let's see them
fight each other yeah I didn't even recognize
him he literally is the guy that got like
his stomach guts blown up but we didn't see
him again for an hour until after we had the
Pedro Willie won't they that was so surprising
I was I was really emotionally caught up in
that because it was a bit of a uh uh we can
recalibration I would say when when it started
introducing the subplots and the different
characters of okay we're getting acquainted
but this is moving a little slower than I
expected and and then before I knew what I
was I'm really pulled into what they're actually
doing and even I think a real switch that
started to happen for me earlier on because
this movie is transitioning into being I think
that's what they got right with the directing
and editing especially was we can't just do
this movie right away we as people first we
have to transition it and it was when he killed
the guys at the um those Wall Street yeah
yeah because it wasn't the cathartic kind
of kill when he first kills the Russian people
in the first movie use because in the when
he first kills the Russian people in the first
movie you're like wow this is freaking surprising
look how cool he is and in this one it's it's
like that scene but instead what you get caught
up in is look how dark of a character he's
because yeah like he is just mer you could
feel the the darkness within him like and
then it was interesting The Duality of that
darkness of like murder is bad with the joy
of like how he's cleaning up his town like
him bopping around in the beginning because
he's like found this purpose like when you
know he rescues the girl he sees her and he
like spins around that pole like there's a
there's a jubilance to him knowing and then
you see him in the act of doing the killing
how like dark that is like how painful it
is yeah and then when Melissa Leo dies like
that was a that seems hard to watch I do like
how they let her at least you know put up
a good fight oh yeah like that made sense
for the character and also you know what the
movie's saying but it was hard to see you
know a 95 pound older woman getting broken
down to these two you know big guys and even
even the choice of the villain of just you're
talking about one of your favorite words Duality
it's a duality of man uh but to make him essentially
another path that Robert like you just want
to call him Denzel but essentially give another
path that Robert himself could have gone down
Robert himself could have reacted that way
as well and just been like I am an assassin
For Hire yeah instead of just kills people
who thinks we're doing bad these are the Craigslist
vigilance yeah he is the Christ did not follow
through now it's all lift driver vigilante
you guys he's just doing all the day labor
jobs in California you got to do different
1099s frankly I hope Denzel's up on it I I
do find the tone shift interesting because
I I not a lot of sequels can change that much
and still feel like the franchise but it still
does yeah like I love when like alien to aliens
is the most prominent example I think of like
completely changing genres and still working
I'm really curious if the third film is a
different thing like do you think it will
still be a drama Thriller pain experience
I don't know I haven't even seen the trailer
for it I don't know if there is one is there
one yeah that's what made me go oh that's
what made me ask you about this okay I was
that removed from this whole like experience
I was going to cover it and then I was like
I don't even remember the first movie so I
gotta watch that oh you could watch that yeah
I'm like I don't know what I would say and
I don't want to read Wikipedia and then I
talk to you and you didn't watch it so I was
like oh man now I got an excuse I'm so glad
I never knew that was a Boston Denzel movie
because I would have watched it and I wouldn't
have had this experience and now I can't wait
for a Boston tinsel free do you know which
one you liked more I think I might like this
one a little bit more I think it would be
like alien and Aliens where I would watch
it depending on mood if I want an action thriller
that's smart I'm gonna watch the first one
if I want to watch a drama that makes me very
very tense and think about dread I'ma watch
this one they're different animals do you
want a burger or pizza because yeah what what
I thought this movie also did surprisingly
really what I would like for the third really
quick when I want to throw out there is what
I would like for the third one is he really
needs to have no pun intended he needs to
have an equal matched villain sure he really
needs that by this point someone who can truly
like he needs a Moriarty yeah yeah and I I
did find that both villains the first one
felt more of a sequel but in his brutality
and then like he felt more of an equal till
we got to the finale right and then it was
suddenly like de-powered but there's Pedro
Pedro Pedro Pascal's character um when he's
up on that thing he gets taken out by like
wires and I was like nah like it just without
that happening how would Denzel who's so calculated
have solve that problem well yeah I thought
that okay that bothered me a bit these guys
have been in the field they've still been
killing and they were people of Denzel used
to um part of his past is connected to them
so I thought that okay this is going to be
a bit of a challenge and I mean yeah it took
a lot of calculation it was still really tense
like I love it that was beautiful the whole
setting of that finale was great I loved it
um that one part of me that I wish it had
was again should have been a little bit harder
for him to this I I don't like that the big
bad was taken out by Nature first I don't
like that the variable wasn't in his control
because he's all that control but that bothered
me a little bit that was such an idiotic that
was an idiotic maneuver for him to be up there
oh 100 yeah it was like and the area kept
him up there and yeah yeah like that was that
was his first downfall speed yeah which was
like that note like I feel like he chose The
High Ground too because he's kind of a coward
right yeah like I'll be the one just died
you just sit up here you guys go get killed
you're like I know a couple you're gonna go
and they all go yeah yeah but like the third
Act is a very unique action set piece like
I can't even imagine designing a hurricane
Cape Cod like yeah I can't imagine what that
set was like I can't imagine what it was like
to have all those variables and the way it
was shot was fascinating I thought it was
I thought that was brilliantly done I I do
wish we got a bit of a minor resolve for Bill
Pullman yeah we don't know it kind of just
that you dropped him off left dropped him
off from the hotel last time we saw was just
anguish yeah yeah and like then moved on yeah
because this movie had more in its mind it
was like a sorrowful reflection it was the
whole story was like a grievance tale this
felt like uh the first one felt like a Punisher
movie and this one felt like old man Frank
like his last mission he's like killing sucks
but it's what I love yeah it's interesting
to get an equalizer three because this feels
like a great ending for it especially for
the fact that he goes home it feels like he's
he he knows he has to do the killing but we
realize that it's not cool to kill like it's
not like a a joyous thing and that's why I
like to do the duality of him being so joyous
while the killing was actually so painful
yeah so I don't know what the third one can
be because those are two very resounding lessons
yeah I hope it's not just a fun action movie
especially after this as I thought this one
this becomes just a silly like I thought it
was gonna be like double the action yeah there's
less action and and but it's I would I really
like the subplots like I like the the characters
in the other one I like the subplots um but
like when miles was in danger oh man I was
so I was on the edge of my seat that Panic
Room scene a lot I really thought it could
go either way yeah I I believe him getting
killed because we liked him enough that I
was like they did that scene right before
where we endeared to the guy yeah so they
might kill him because that's what you do
you make him you make it love the kid and
then you kill him so it like Denzel's got
Vengeance to write yeah the first one's more
clever in the sense of like what's cool about
both these movies is they both have it by
the Numbers kind of plot yeah by the Numbers
action plot it's what makes them special is
the way they execute them and not just with
its action scenes but its overall storytelling
like when we watch first equalizer as I I
don't recall like how great of a character
this guy is written yeah you know and in that
movie you're really witnessing him in the
perspective of how others witness him and
this one you're more in his POV yeah you live
with him as a character here yeah he's less
of a shark just causing things yeah yeah yeah
like that one you're like look how cool he
is yeah because it's Denzel you're just like
oh and you know what by the end hair made
it better because like that made it a different
character as did his hair I think the visual
difference of like him helped me like in the
first I think the opening him being bald I
think that was a subconscious like this is
a man that's changed true yeah there it seems
like there was a deliberate choice right because
he's bald in the beginning of the Moon equalizer
one equalizer or was it just a choice to show
a passage of time of how long he's been equalizing
they didn't really give us that though it
didn't I didn't care as it indicator it's
clearly been two to three months but like
I don't know how fast hair grows but like
clearly like it felt like a different not
character but characterization of the character
yeah I wonder if he's bald in three and we'll
find out what kind of Mission Impossible [__]
is his hair long or short this time what tone
are we gonna get by Denzel's hair either way
I mean I know Denzel's like the guy like I
feel like when people talk about the great
actors it's Denzel and this franchise shows
how you can make an action franchise way more
interesting by having someone that powerful
because the scene with him and miles is like
that scene in the in the lobby right after
the elevator is one of the most beautiful
scenes I've seen about making a choice about
which way your life's gonna go and the way
he breaks him down the way he builds him back
up the way he then threatens him the way he
gives him power the way like all of those
moments and Dynamics in like what four minutes
that was incredible acting from both of them
that wouldn't work with most actors and I
like how you can tell that part of what propels
him there is the pain that he's feeling from
the loss of his friend right and now he's
trying to save this person you could tell
that becomes a thing where he just has to
get involved uh and he doesn't even have to
say it just like don't become like me it didn't
have to like look at my eyes is everything
he needs to say about like what that world
is yeah I was I was wild I thought the gangsters
would come back in some way I liked that that
that I like that the movies that are in this
genre normally would have been that yeah because
yeah the first one's kind of by their own
response so is this yeah this time it's more
personal his friend died yeah his old party
he's got to go back into and go back home
and take out his partner but yeah how do you
deliver it but how you deliver it is it in
its whole Ambiance like this entire mood was
was so different like I found myself just
we didn't talk at all yeah and that you're
welcome yes because the 2.5 is just sucked
in I don't know that's the thing about scenes
yeah this is gonna be like a 30 minute watch
because like we were so in it I found I found
myself often like because I think in the first
one there were times where I was like okay
let's go back to some of the action the first
one was fun to watch with someone because
it was like a party and this one was hard
to watch like I kept forgetting I was on camera
so it was hard to watch on camera because
I kept being like and I kept forgetting to
like do the thing I'd like to make a comment
right yeah because it was hard to share it
because I was like yeah that was I was sucked
into that one I was I'm really surprised by
how how transportative of an experience that
was I was very immersed in a very painful
way like I'm very tense I'm very exhausted
I'm very like uh affected by the violence
I I don't do well with Ultraviolence I used
to I used to love like you know slashers and
brutal violent movies of like you know action
but the older I get the more uh it affects
me in a way that like I don't like to put
myself in that position I don't like to like
I don't want two hours of pain that I can
avoid and I know that you know some people
find catharsis and horror and some people
find like enjoyment and brutal action but
there's something in me that like it it's
just putting myself in pain for longer and
like life's hard so it was weird to watch
that and be like I don't want to experience
assault of people because why and in a good
way it was successful but it made it so like
yeah killing's bad like I felt that it's what
I like your Punisher comparison though yeah
because my mind immediately went to but how
did koi enjoy Punisher uh so the first season
of Punisher I thought really delivered on
this is a man that only knows pain so he has
to inflict pain and I think one of the things
that I didn't like about season two of Punisher
was it then became a man striking Vengeance
as Revenge without it being any sort of um
nothing seemed to impact his emotionality
he was just rage and that's that's what I
struggled with with John Wick 3 compared to
one two and four is John Wick 3 like the Artistry
of the gun fu and the and the pain of it doesn't
feel like it's as important as the cool and
and so I like the violence of John Wick movies
because it's so removed from reality it doesn't
feel like I'm living it but the thing these
movies do is is I feel like I watch someone
get beaten to death and I don't like that
but it that's the good of it succeeding yeah
yeah because the pun also the other thing
that came up with the Punisher comparison
was the fact that this reflected on the the
fact they're both vets right you know and
that we with the way we treat vets and the
way you can go after because there is a a
ticking clock of usefulness to the government
that when it runs out is it private sector
or VA is it you know some of the homeless
people in La is it like and and that you know
it's a it's another cliche writing action
thing of like now I'm private and it was delivered
a bit more uh in a in a painful way here it
was delivered in a way that's you know I have
nothing left this is my wife and kids like
Denzel just killed that guy's that wife's
husband and like you have to live that I thought
this was a kind of a bold way to do a sequel
I thought this was really bold yeah because
I bet if we put on the trailer it would just
be like a cool it's the open movie yeah I
bet they would take a lot of these seeds just
make it look like it's just a bitching movie
isn't it look at him kicking ass yeah and
I don't feel like they would communicate at
all with the actual feeling of this movie
is and I have no because of the sequel I have
no idea what the third one is as I remember
like I used to kind of follow Anton fuqua's
career a little bit better and I sort of fell
off the map a little bit obviously I haven't
seen freaking pleasure too so um but you know
like he did I didn't know I did like the Replacement
Killers which was a cool action movie and
all would um which had a lot of drama but
it was like really for the action you watch
it and then they needed like training day
and you know like equalizers I don't see any
of the training day in that no but here I
see the training day of this collaboration
of Denzel and and Tom Fuqua like I could see
that in here you see why this is his first
sequel like you see what the pitch was that
makes it worth Denzel and Anthony you know
when people say we have to do a sequel if
the story is good and it matters and justifies
it a lot of times you're like what a load
of crap this was like no I see it like they
really had something they wanted to tell and
it feels like honestly they made the first
movie to get to this one
and then we'll make ours you gotta get that
Vibe yeah because this felt way more like
what I'd expect from a Denzel movie not like
you know I I was I love the first one but
it's very much like we got Denzel in an action
movie so it's gonna have more Nuance this
one is like there's a lot of nuance we've
sprinkled in some action yeah it felt more
like they LED I mean the first one still does
feel like Denzel you get like a different
side of density to get that fatherly side
of him I mean he is that you get those fatherly
qualities of course you know with Chloe Grace
everyone else who's mentoring left and right
he's a life coach everywhere he goes sure
but this one they become a lot more direct
we're with him in Miles where it's it's very
much a parenting yeah the first one felt like
an uncle this one felt like a dad yeah like
an uncle that's like coming in fixing stuff
giving you a lesson yeah this one's like I
gotta raise this kid's gonna sit in a rocking
chair and he's gonna listen to me yeah this
was so powerful I and that's why when you
ask that everyone like better it's it's pizza
or Burgers it's it's they're different meals
they're different nourishments they're different
flavors equalize as much as first one's much
easier to put on 100 but this is the one I'm
like all right guys let's turn the lights
off let's pay attention this one's plated
this is one of those restaurants that plates
their food this one's got like fancy garnish
on it and it's still a really like good meal
but it's a lot more complicated and then the
first one's like I like pizza two pizzas the
gun on top because there's no scene in here
even with the action there's no I I would
probably watch like the finale action back
again as like a study for sure it's a scene
I would just put on but like there's scenes
there's action scenes at the first one where
you're like I just want to see this cool moment
play that again play that again whereas uh
here even even this some of the coolest part
like the the car chase scene that was so sick
it was so well crafted and a lot of times
car chase scenes I'm not I normally don't
really love a lot of them sure I think a lot
of times they're like really choppy and they
don't feel that cool and you gotta find you
gotta find that right line and I thought that
was a really well edited and shot uh car chase
sequence that had a really good Crescendo
at the end and even that was this is really
suspenseful it's not I'm not just watching
look how cool right yeah and I know he survives
but I still was in suspense like obviously
he doesn't stab him to death like you know
that the bad guy's gonna lose it you're still
invested they did such a good job making it
tense it's funny how this movie is also 20
minutes shorter because it feels it feels
like four hours but in a complimentary way
it feels it feels longer uh because it really
feels like it took its time and I and I'm
more exhausted like it feels like I cannot
describe how I feel I'm very like flattened
out by this movie how was that two hours and
two minutes because I'm I'm wrecked yeah I
mean yeah that's a lot it's surprising how
sure it was into the across the spider versus
longest movie that's funny when we saw across
the spider verse I remember watching it going
how long is this long I didn't know the run
time runtime 220. I did you know it the first
time we watched it because I was really excited
the first time you watched it yeah I thought
it was like because the run time came out
and I was like whoa this is not the movie
that they I think they're advertising and
that gave me actually more faith in it and
then it delivered I thought we were walking
into a 90-minute animated movie no so when
it kept going I was like wow this is really
long but I don't want it to end well because
the tone it's also like this one where it's
like we're gonna totally change the tone of
the movie actually oddly enough spider-verse
one to two is way more in common with this
than John Wick wanted to do oh a thousand
percent I thought this would do what John
Wayne who did where is it spider verse like
better like cooler action scenes uh but this
was like now we're gonna we're gonna zero
in and just give you like more characters
yeah and uh and we're gonna trust the pace
to be ponderous and like painful I really
did like Pedro Pascal's performance there
is a number in my head though that I kept
having to do every time you showed up on screen
I can never just see the character because
I'm so aware of Pedro Pascal and the amount
of freaking interviews I have seen of him
this year alone yep so many interviews that
I was so aware every time he was on screen
of what is younger Pedro Pascal before he
was Pedro Pascal like how was this five years
ago that man has had some City miles put on
him in this press tour because he looks a
lot I don't know that's why it doesn't return
in the suit because it wore down on him in
Mandalore how much makeup was on Peter Pascal
to make him this young in this movie and he's
actually aging better I think like he's aged
in a way that he's more ruggedly handsome
he's got one of those things where the salt
and pepper look and all that it totally works
better because you're right he looked deep
fake to a point I was like who's this cyborg
paper Pascal a little strange like I I the
young one made me uncomfortable yeah but like
it's like I've never seen super young Clint
Eastwood but even then he looks like 40. like
he's always had a weathered face because he's
playing yeah imagine like a wrinkle freak
Clint Eastwood how weird that would look even
Scott looks like 40 at Birth they both have
that like a son Scott Eastwood from the fast
movies oh like they close they have that Sunday
no they have that thing where they just have
that like they get better and better more
weathered I feel like Pedro Pascal has that
yeah I definitely think he has that I still
was able to whenever I move past those thoughts
I was still able to see the performance for
what it was and I thought he actually did
a really great job him and Denzel read off
each other very well yeah that scene in the
bench was great the the win makes it interesting
line was delightful but even villain reveal
scene was done really well like I love the
way that was done I read I I like how he doesn't
just descend into
are we gonna get a monologue no we got like
this really cool scene in a kitchen that felt
like a scene in a kitchen it felt like that's
why I kept saying fences this movie feels
like a drama set in houses and fences like
it does that Kingsman he also plays government
man who also betrays apparently mid-30s Pedro
face was government man and now rugged Pedro
in his late 30s 40s his daddy man Daddy's
doing the work and this one he actually was
a father and yeah the guy plays Miles do you
know the actor's name I don't know his name
but I really like his work Kia he's amazing
so in in Wu-Tang in American Saga he plays
Rizza and I don't know how much you know about
Wu-Tang Clan but Rizza was one of the most
instrumental figures in hip-hop where he was
able to be a producer and artist an actual
rapper and basically started the business
and he combined multiple sounds of like different
styles of hip-hop from like Staten Island
and Brooklyn and all these different places
and he was one of the original MCS that mixed
sounds from like other mediums so he was like
Gathering uh dialogue scenes from like uh
you know Kung Fu movies and putting it over
like beats and all these things yeah and yeah
so that's what the actor needs to be able
to do is be someone convincing of like I'm
gonna make everything work with all of these
disparate parts and make it seem like I can
deliver all that while also being a guy that
runs a crew that's 12 people strong and why
it's important so he's got like that job as
an actor is impossible to be like I'm this
you know 10 things that Rizza is but also
be so charismatic that it's not a boring Exposition
dumb and to be able to keep up Denzel you
know I don't know how old dude is but like
what an incredible force of a 20 something
I do want to look I I feel because you always
hear those stories about Denzel where he like
brings people under his wing yeah I mean he
got Chadwick start yes as one example of yeah
of Ted zelp being like as I'm sure the guy
probably had to screen test with Denzel um
but let's see if there's some like facts on
it um because I also want another dude's name
because he he's great I would like to know
he's skinny but I think if he bumped up he'd
be such a good Bishop 6.7 oh people went into
this thing and they'd get an action movie
oh yeah I could totally see where people would
be disappointed with it Orson Bean is it the
light you passed uh Ashton Sanders yeah Ashton
Sanders okay that's actually it's a pretty
easy name to remember Ashton Sanders is on
his third build on the uh Little Stars list
there well deserved uh I think an American
Saga is one of the best shows that not enough
people are talking about it just finished
its three season run it wrapped yeah it was
his first sequel yep good call uh okay hold
on they want the fight seems to be as realistic
as possible Tyrone Woodley trained Denzel
that's cool as hell I love that Target Woodley's
fantastic the sequelizer that's funny
uh okay
come on I'm trying to find that one fact but
I'm finding myself like wanting to read all
the facts yeah Donald Cerrone trained two
man Cowboys one of my favorite Fighters I
love that two UFC fighters maybe more helped
Denzel get even more badass
[Music] oh this is all the tax credits in
Boston that makes sense okay I just want to
look up how this guy you could look up like
it might be easier Google like Ashton Ashton
Sanders and Denzel Washington Denzel Washington
it's got to be like something here it's like
look they're like interviews together for
promoting the movie yeah have they been into
other stuff together oh he oh I didn't realize
I haven't seen Moonlight yet I didn't realize
he was in it is he yeah it just said Moonlight
Breakout Moonlight breakout Ashton Sanders
continue to have their surrogate father-son
relationship for sure for the movie moonlight
uh it says Moonlight breakout oh we're holding
the moon my star is like a phrase oh no like
moonlights and quotes uh yeah they're doing
these interviews together
come on give me a fact just give me a fact
exploration of the surrogate father-son relationship
uh in the script who also wrote helped the
bones were there hadn't met Ashton yet and
the idea was good he said you know the mentor
mentee relationship only gurus we got to know
each other that became a conversation between
takes it was natural because I have two sons
and he was like my third son so it doesn't
sound like he actually brought him on if you
didn't know him before I was like you knew
him before he's up but he said uh he said
wait didn't I just really didn't I hadn't
met Ashton yet ah oh wow which surprises me
because their their relationship was incredible
that's cool okay so you see how Ashton Sanders
got his start yeah because like this is gonna
be 20 minutes of my coin I just reading just
like how would you like to watch us read uh
continuous people relate to um yeah no this
guy's like so good all right that's sweet
guys well what did you think about The Equalizer
too guys do you think it's better than the
first do we avoid the trailer for three it's
already out right yeah the yes we've gotten
this far right like is it unless it plays
in front of the movie in the next like week
in theaters it's gonna be out of the trailer
rotation yeah you're right I mean what if
there's a trailer too we could react to it
for people that watch these and then like
have that but then we'd know too much I don't
know if I won because trailer two is their
story I don't know if I want to see a trailer
I I I'll avoid it'd be pretty cool to avoid
the trailer and just go in like who's the
Pedro and David Harbor of the third one like
who's that actor that we're like oh my God
I did have one thing spoiled for me of who's
in it oh okay um this is not not the villain
but a
if you manage to avoid this information that
would be awesome I will try is it Bill Burr
no good it'll make you'd laugh for sure I
don't want to say anything okay but I mean
it's set in Boston it's gonna make sure found
out and I was like really that of course gonna
flap laugh at this I mean I hope Ash and Sanders
is in it kid's great guy I haven't looked
up at any of the cast no no I found out who
one of the cast members was and I was like
oh that's cool I'm like oh and I was like
oh that's so funny I'm so curious now Isaiah
you all know why when you when I when I find
out yeah is it something that uh when does
it come out September yeah yeah so we will
probably get it like November October it's
a 45 day window oh is that the thing that's
what it all is how I map out my okay let's
reacting so late it's 45 days from when Transformers
comes so we could do yeah we'll have an October
uh movie to look forward to in the dry season
there's no dry season here
[Laughter] uh this was so different than I
expected uh I'm really happy we just like
had that I think craving hundreds out in October
though uh and and I'm so glad it was so different
because we spent the whole time like silently
wondering what this movie was in such a good
way um I'm curious what the overall consensus
though unfavorite is because they're two different
movies like yeah well let me know in the comments
which which of the two you like and why well
we'll see you guys in October that's when
koi will finally return to the channel that's
it not until then not for all the things we're
doing between now and then that's then attraction
two secret Invasion also I mean like in this
in this series in the movie series yeah that's
right and also of course comic Conor and trailers
I'll be here and the minions obviously that's
a great extraction great journey next day
Brewing it up just having a time let's just
I think there's no Steve Carell in that one
I think let's just have more feeling oh man
could you imagine just the sounds and not
like an actor to Anchor it how maddening that
would be no thank you I think we should just
really have just constant just pure chaos
pure chaos and no smoothness in what we choose
just totally left field next we should watch
like a very intense drama that's not fun to
watch us watch like a three hour like Oscar
Bait film that's like really dry all right
guys after watching extraction two we are
doing the English patients I hear it's a fun
one you know it's gonna be a romp a real good
time alrighty guys peace out reject Nation
[Music]